Thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
this video.
I think we can all agree that rogue one
is by no means a conventional entry into
the Star Wars Saga,
the black and gray undertones of the
opening sequence,
and it's boots on the ground,
no nonsense approach to it.
Story for veal early on that the film is
the odd one out at a midst a long series
of familiar expectations taking place in
between the overall darker and best and
mystic revenge of the sith and the more
hopeful and optimistic and new hope.
It functions as a mediator of what we
can call the Yin and the Yang of the
star wars saga.
Bridging not only to chronological gap
in the timeline,
but also and more importantly,
symbolically crossing the underlying
tonal divide that exists between these
two films.
This voyage begins close through the
darkness of revenge of the Sith,
the young gender or so,
and her family who have been hiding in
the shadows of the galaxy are found by
the tyrannical empire who proceed to
shoot her,
define mother and forced her genius
fodder,
Gayland Urso to finish constructing the
death star with the archetype of a
rental.
Figures effectively eliminated the
film's opening.
Sequence not only sets up Jen's
backstory as to protagonist,
but it also symbolically establishes the
main dominating theme or undertone of
roughly the first half of the film,
which is the world at the bottom and in
the shadow.
Fifteen years down the line,
jen is shown to have become a criminal
and a prisoner in a remote imperial
labor camp,
having grown disillusioned and cynical
throughout the year,
she doesn't rejoice at the prospect of
being rescued by the rebels,
but attempts to fight them off.
Instead.
Her nihilistic worldview has made,
are numb to any sort of belief or dream
anymore benevolent future.
Her only interest are selfish in nature
and grounded at the bottom in the
material world.
You can stand to see the imperial flag.
Brain crossed,
not a problem if you don't.
The rebel alliance on it's Bart is
shown,
fractured its members,
anxious and divided,
separated by conflicting opinions on the
conduct of war.
It's agents operating on the fringes of
morality.
Gas.
Ian is one of these agents and
represents this inner conflict in his
struggle to live with the questionable
things he sees himself forced to do in
servers off the rebellion,
the alliances,
motives are seemingly egoic and
dishonest in nature,
only having rescued gin as a means of
getting to her father and lying to her
about the ultimate goal of the mission.
Forget what you heard in that there will
be no extraction.
You find him.
This morally slippery slope is
accentuated by two character of Saul
Guerrera,
the former mentor of gin and the leader
of an extremist rebel cell function
somewhat as a cautionary tale for the
alliance as a whole.
He and his men have been engaged in a
brutal war against the empire and the
city of Jeddah booting civilian lives in
danger and combating the imperials over
who the moral high ground in the city
hiding in a crumbling desert cave with
his window into the world shattered saw
has slowly become more machine than men
having grown exceedingly paranoid of
others as his sanity and humanity
dwindled along the way.
Moving beyond the merely human
representation of the world.
At the bottom is the entire planet of
Jetta,
a small desert.
Planet.
Jetta was once a spiritual world of
worship for forest believers and to jet.
I order.
However,
when we get to see is a world in
decline,
the giant statues of Ancient Jetta I
have fallen and are crumbling.
It's city upon a hill like John
winthrop's,
Massachusetts Bay colony.
It was once a place for people to look
up to a place of honor,
hope,
justice,
and the highest possible good in rogue
one.
However,
the city has fallen into decay.
It streets ravaged by war.
It's skies shrouded by a pyramid shape,
star,
destroyer and ultimate symbol of bloated
order,
and it's amongst roaming the streets
without purpose as dare temple is
actively being plundered of its most
valuable resource guide holding these
star crystals were formerly used to make
jet I lightsabers and our sources of the
force of the light in the darkness
representing such things as order
justice and moral good gins,
necklace holes,
one of these stones which is noticed by
the blind monk Chirrut
the first thing this quote seems to
address as Jen's inner journey,
perhaps implying that she should listen
to to deepest urgings over hard to let
go of her apathetic nature and to move
yourself upwards towards a higher
purpose to become a beacon of light in
the darkness.
The second preference comes into form of
the newly constructed Deathstar,
which powered by the ems crystals from
Jetta possesses eight literal heart of
Geiber to director Orson Krennic.
This literal manifestation gold,
a star powered by Dick Lehman Crystal
will ultimately translate into a better
world to providing peace cured.
However,
it is notion of the absolute order of
light becomes instead something
pathological and highly destructive,
symbolically suggesting that a world
with too much light or too much order is
just as bad as a world consumed by
darkness and chaos.
These two notions of lightness as moral
good and the danger of the excess of
light then come together at the climax
of the jetta sequence gins,
existing inner cynical beliefs are
shattered when she's confronted with a
Hologram message of her long lost father
speaking to her as to symbolical spirit
of the fodder to culture and the order
that has been consumed by the tyranny of
the empire.
He tells her of his true intentions to
eight to rebellion and the destruction
of the deaths are down by leaving gin
with a message of hope and sacrificed to
a higher purpose.
But at the same time of the resurrection
of the wives.
Father,
his tyrannical counterpart blooms high
above shrouding the light of the sun
before finally destroying the remnants
of the old order like a god thunder on
the people of his creation with the land
now shrouded in darkness and chaos.
It's horizon rendered,
nonexistent.
Saw Jim's father figure decides that he
will run no longer with his sacrifice,
symbolizing the embracing of his own
darkness and his message of trust in a
higher good.
The group escapes not only death,
but also manages to climb out of the
symbolical world at the bottom.
The story then starts to take the shape
of the archetypical ascension journey
that has its hero climb out of the
shadow is sending a mountain towards the
highest possible,
good redeeming or changing himself and
the people around him for the better at
the top.
This upward journey in rogue one is then
mirrored by a descend into chaos and
into the belly of the beast on the one
hand to embrace and overcome every
character's personal,
dark,
side or shadow,
and on the other hand,
to save the spirit of the fodder which
holds the key to the reemergence of hope
and a more benevolent order for gaseous.
This means that he has to confront the
darker nonthinking side of his character
in order to free himself from the mental
prison.
Net clouds is hard.
It was more than once
with the ultimate physical death will
for fodder.
Gin on her part has to finally move
beyond her empathetic nature in favor of
belief and hope and self sacrifice for a
higher good.
I would argue that it's this change in
these two characters that slowly begins
to trickle down into other individuals
and eventually the rebel collective as a
whole.
Jen and her broke one task force are
really the tip of the spear of the
rebellion.
They are at a bow and Arrow,
double,
ultimately pointy entire alliance into a
new direction,
embracing both the light and the dark
and individually choosing to sacrifice
themselves for a greater good,
and it's exactly dispersonal sacrifice
in service of a better future that
allows roque one to make it's final
ascend to the top and to broadcast a
blueprint of the fodder that holds the
key for a better world to reemerge down
the line.
Because even though does sacrifice will
ultimately come at the cost of all of
these characters lives,
it is not so much shown to be a negative
as it is transcendent in his last
moments.
The imperial defector Bodie overcome
this fear and shows courage in his heart
as he establishes the radio connection
needed for the success of the mission.
Witnessing the heroic demise of his
friend Charit.
This skeptical realist base has a last
minute change of heart and finally puts
his trust in to force horse.
Even the analytical Kaytoo shows a sign
of humanity through his mechanical
exterior in the end.
It's a line of courageous sacrifice
based on hope and trust into force that
really all started with the define death
of gins.
Mother followed by countless other
allied characters from saw and galen to
numerous named and unnamed rebel marines
and air force wings to cash in and jen
themselves.
Their deaths are marked by an exuberant
and transcendent lightness,
giving us a sense of redemption in a
positively charged sacrifice.
And it's here at the battle of
[inaudible] that the rebel alliance has
really defined setting itself apart from
the tyrannical pathology and destructive
selfishness of the empire and not just
because of its physical action of moving
out of the shadow and facing the empire
head on.
But more importantly,
because of the all of inspiring action
of a select few individuals,
Roque one,
demonstrates that to save oneself is to
save the galaxy.
It's about having the courage to climb
out of the bottom of the pit to defy
overwhelming darkness,
both without and within,
and to move upwards and self sacrifice
of the ICO itself,
in order to retrieve the spirit of the
father,
it's to emulate his star with a heart of
Cairo,
to be an inspiration for others to do
the same in hopes of manifesting a
better future for all.
Nobody's listening.
All right.
Thank you all so much for watching and
thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
this video.
If you haven't heard of them before,
squarespace is by far the easiest to use
and most elegant website builder is.
We recently used it to build our own
website within no time.
And that's coming from someone who knows
absolutely zero about coding.
Now,
if you're interested,
you can get a free trial period in which
you can design your complete website
with a not satisfied money back
guarantee.
And if you go to
squarespace.com/storytellers and type in
our storytellers,
you get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
The link is in the description.
Now,
if you want to support us in another
way,
you can become our patron or leave as a
tip on paypal.
Thanks for watching guys.
See you in the next one.